so as many people know I was on vacation
if you were following me on instagram
you know that I was in the country of
Italy and it was very very interesting
and I'm going to talk more about the
details of my trip on the bonus show
today but I have a story that i'm going
to tell because it's a horrifying story
that I I just want to share with people
uh I talked before going on this trip
that I've actually in this was in
relation to the story about Hillary
Clinton's health that I had a few
fainting episodes including 15 years ago
on a flight to Portugal uh and it
happened again on the flight back from
Italy about halfway through the flight
about four hours in near Iceland or
Greenland or somewhere I started to feel
sick uh again and within about 30
seconds the next thing I remember is the
entire plane is basically looking at me
and there's three people asking me
questions as I come to and my girlfriend
is two rows back in the aisle with three
people trying to call her calm her down
and she's going completely crazy and I
realized I fainted again on the plane
and this was definitely the scariest
medical incident that I've had in my
life sort of an acute thing were just
something happened that was really
beyond my control to put it quite
literally and uh via fortunately there
were there were a number of doctors on
board or but there were a couple doctors
uh and a nurse and they took my blood
pressure and it was a min to tell you
that this was a scene would be a drastic
understatement they were talking
potentially alitalia was talking about
whether they need to land the plane in
Greenland as a result of this incident
which bull as embarrassed as I was about
what happened if the plane lands in
Greenland I'm not going to feel too good
about my participation and involvement
in this flight at which was already
delayed by nearly an hour uh so yeah uh
dr. Anthony's asya was there and he was
able to observe me and had me drink a
liter and a half of water thinking I was
sort of dehydrated he he chalked it up
to what is called a vasovagal incident
which I have a history of
and uh I'm I'm going to be getting
checked out obviously I spoke to someone
at my doctors office when I landed they
said listen we know your history of this
unless you're still feeling ill let's
make an appointment to have you come in
a few days you don't need to go to an
emergency room but this really was very
scary and that the scariest thing at
meet for me at this point is I can sort
of think about what might have caused
this right so there's there's a few
things that that can cause these issues
for people who have this tendency and uh
part of this is for me just getting up
quickly right three I wanna say four of
the six incidents I've had in my life
like this happen when I just got up in
the middle of the night to go to the
bathroom or get water without first
sitting on the edge of my bed and sort
of letting the blood flow a sort of sort
of normalize and so number one I have a
tendency for this to happen uh number
two if you have a a large meal so to
speak or a full meal and you're already
on a plane which is pressurized to
around 6,500 to 7,000 feet i believe so
slightly higher than in denver colorado
uh you already have lower oxygen levels
in the air uh so if someone is sort of
prone to these incidents they will
already be more likely to have one you
have a meal and then an hour and a half
later which is exactly the way it
happened on my flight to portugal your
body is using more blood for the
digestion process which again is away
from your head that's another factor and
i don't know maybe my doctor is going to
tell me i need to avoid having a full
meal on a plane uh okay maybe that's one
thing number two i had a glass of wine
on the plane which I normally don't do
overseas flights you get free wine and
they were just coming around with wine
and as it sure I'll have a glass of
white wine and uh of course alcohol
further uh dilating the the blood
vessels and allowing blood to more
freely flow out of my uh out out of my
brain and I don't know I mean that the
scariest part is just not being able to
predict it basically since I was eight
years old roughly every five years I've
had one of
these incidents the last one was in
December of 20 uh 2011 as I mentioned
going to Portugal and that was like I
fainted for about 10 seconds this I mean
who knows because nobody really could
tell me but they said it was closer to
like a minute that I was out and uh I I
don't know what else to say literally my
girlfriend said she she thought I was
dying she wasn't sure that this wasn't
me dying and uh the the confusion that I
experienced when I woke up and I
remember for a split second uh i
remembered i started to wake up and I
remembered having felt a little nauseous
and I had a relief for I said oh I've
been sleeping this is so good I ended up
not feeling sick I remembered feeling
sick but it went away and I've just been
dozing and then people are asking me am
I diabetic people i don't know are
asking me if I'm on any medication if
I'm on any kind of of of drugs and
recreational drugs if uh I'm having
potentially like drug addiction
withdrawal symptoms or uh whether I I
had food I didn't have food there's a
blood pressure cuff on me uh there's
someone uh looking in my eyes with a
flashlight this if I I have no other way
to describe it as incredibly scary and
uh you you may hear more about this on
uh on on my social media once once I
have more information about it uh I
don't really know what else to say that
incident took place it is incredibly
scary what I know for sure and I have to
fly again in a few weeks out which makes
me a little nervous i will say
absolutely no more wine or alcohol of
any kind on the flight and I would even
go further and say before the flight in
the entire day leading up to the flight
there will be absolutely no alcohol
consumption and I really do have to
think about this uh this meal thing
because both times that this happened
that the Portugal trip five years ago
and then over the weekend here uh it was
within about 90 maybe more like a
hundred and twenty minutes after eating
the the meal and uh very very scary
stuff
fortunately I ended up making it through
the entire flight without having to have
an emergency landing in Greenland and uh
uh I I could be in Greenland right now
if that had happened so fortunately that
didn't happen that's the story uh if
anybody has any tips by all means let me
know 11 uh person on the flight said the
second you start to feel this coming on
you should lean over and basically tuck
your head between your knees because
it'll force blood into your brain the
thing is this happened so quickly and
when you just feel nauseous bending over
in that way doesn't feel like the most
appealing thing usually you want to put
your head back so I I it sounds like a
possibility but uh I don't know needless
to say the trip otherwise was absolutely
fantastic and I will talk about that on
the bonus show uh but first we do have a
voicemail number